but didn't you have to do some intimate
scenes oh i mean
people have i don't know if you guys
have done any any filming and
you know um you know a lot of the slopes
i think have used perspex
screens which i i think must be very odd
we didn't do that we
um one one thing we we did do was uh i
did have a scene we were outside happily
um
uh and i i had a kind of scene where i
had to get a little bit
it's a bit spoilery but i had to get a
little bit intimate with another
character and and get closer than you're
really able to
um and someone had the brilliant idea of
bringing in this actor's
poor wife um and putting a wig on her
and and doubling her for me so i right
i i so i go up to this point in the
scene
where i i have to move closer and then
you can i step to the side and his wife
steps in
and i just stand there at the side like
this just looking
you know really awkward and so they have
this moment and then i just step back in
and carry on
shooting yeah we didn't we didn't do
that they just tested us
like angry tested like every second day
yeah you know so i was literally gagging
and then by the end of it i was like
typing away on the laptop thing
just had so many it didn't bother me
constantly everybody's constantly
constantly being tested they're you know
they they really feel like plus i'm a
different race to the person's partner
so that would have probably been an
issue
yeah yeah yeah that's more than a week
can you imagine that
yeah something odd just happened
continuity very often that was a bit
gotten for him like he gets to go
outside he's like today's the day i get
to kiss
keely [ __ ] horse this is great and
there's like your wife's here she's
what i've seen and you know damn well
his wife didn't want to kiss him
[Music]